ok so again about zach braff you know
when people one other thing and maybe I
touched on this earlier is that you have
to remember there was a time when
Kickstarter started and then people
weren't raising that much money that me
and peter broderick and a number of
people are saying that you don't do
Kickstarter for money you do it for
engagement you know you do it for
audience building and so you know Zach
Braff even though he's rich doesn't
necessarily have a connection with his
audience but why are you if he's
starting to create one why would you
hold that against him I think it's great
i mean we everyone in my world says it's
important for artists to start engaging
with their audience and have a
connection with them so is that only for
artists who are unknown like why is it
bad for you know kevin smith to have a
relationship with this audience or again
I'll say Tarantino who I think is right
for this and so that's one additional
issue I guess the issue you were saying
as far as if the film goes into profit
you know I think so why were people not
upset about Louis CK going direct to fan
for his comedy special people celebrated
that and then when he was hugely
successful he started donating the money
to charity so you know give Zach Braff a
break you know maybe if his film goes
into profit then maybe he'll do
something great with the money you know
it's like you know I don't know him you
know I can't say what he will or won't
do but you know you I am again it's mr.
Pollyanna I like to think that you know
generally artists when they get money
tend to do good things with their money
as opposed to other kinds other people
who make a lot of money and often don't
do good things with their money you know
so you know let's just be hopeful and
think that you know if he makes his film
and its successful that in some way he
shares the wealth on someone on some
level you know
you